[Musique]
quelqu'un là-bas, nous le sortons bien en
présentant Axel la dernière
protection militaire avec reconnaissance faciale
sur les systèmes de sangle Ward et les
capacités d'appariement du propriétaire, il est maintenant jumelé, le
gâteau contrôle l'ensemble du projet que
vous voulez jouer, allons-y,
je veux  montrez-vous quelque chose bonjour parlez-
lui ouais restez
mon garçon faites donc tout ce que j'ai dit mais
quelqu'un a dépensé beaucoup d'argent pour eux,
ils ont tout le monde à l'étranger je ne
pense pas que son propriétaire mérite de les récupérer
j'ai besoin de savoir ce qu'il fait c'est
évoluant bien au-delà des attentes c'est
mon chien je veux qu'il revienne
lancez les médicaments allez
avez-vous besoin de notre aide
ce que vous devriez faire est de le rendre
le nouvel emplacement emménagez pour la
récupération
[Musique]
embarquez ceci ensemble
vous
[Musique]